das ist richtig spannend das sind verborgene
Reichtümer ja uralte Schatzkarten und sie sie
spielen den Helden wirklich diesmal einmal wie
Captain Jack Sparrow an einem Ankertau über
ein vier Master in der Karibik schwingen ja ja so
können was machen oder so wie ich das geschrieben
habe am Sie versuchen ein Immobilieneigentümer
ausfindig zu machen und zwar in Deutschland sie
können Ihren Zuschauern keine Atempause was
ja wir folgen jetzt strengen dem erzählmodell
der Heldenreise nach Joseph Campbell ich
spiele den Bösewicht ja also russische
versucht Geldwäsche in Deutschland ich habe
halt illegal erworbenes Geld und damit kaufe
ich mir jetzt diese schicke kleine Prachtvilla
ja und damit verwandle ich schmutziges Geld in
sauberes Vermögen ja und wen spiele ich na ja
sie sind der Held der versucht zu verhindern
dass er seinen bekannten Verbrecher ein anonymer
Immobilienbesitzer wird dann mache ich das jetzt
so sehr schön
jetzt online Grundbuch und dann
werde ich verhindern dass diese
Immobilie von einem Verbrecher gekauft wird
ein Moment seit ich vergessen zu erwähnen es
gibt keinen bundesweites digitales
Grundbuch in Deutschland sie müssen
sich teilweise durch 100 Jahre alte Schriften
kämpfen das ist quasi nach Joseph Campbell hallo
Teil 1 der Heldenreise der Ruf des Abenteuers
das schaue ich doch jetzt nicht alles durch
Teil 2 der Heldenreise die Weigerung ich kann das
überhaupt nicht lesen ja das ist die erste Prüfung
für unseren Helden die Sütterlinschrift da ist
aber die Fantasie mit den durchgegangen oder nein
nein das Realität im deutschen Grundbuchamt
hatten sie doch in der Grundschule oder
das soll ich jetzt alles lesen
hält liest versprochen
da finde ich sie da finde ich sie ja nie ja das
kann daran liegen dass ich im Grundbuch gar nicht
drin stehe wieso aber das ist doch ihr Haus das
ist doch da drin das ist so mein Firmensitz sehen
Sie also quasi gehört das meinem Unternehmen
hier die Immobilie der sagen wir mal Haus von
Wagner GmbH ja dann ist das ja aus was heißt das
sogar wie sie wie heißt das Haus von Wagner GmbH
ach so dann schaue ich jetzt nach wem diese GmbH
gehört das ist sehr clever vor
allem weil seit 2017 Deutschland
ein Transparenzregister für Unternehmen
besitzt wahrscheinlich in Keilschrift oder
nein es gibt sogar online was sO muss modernes
haben wir ja da leider Deutschland hat harter
gegen gekämpft aber die EU hat sich durchgesetzt
aber hier steht gar kein Besitzer von dieser GmbH
drin sie haben sich nicht ins Transparenzregister
eingetragen boah nee echt oh oh da ist das wohl
wieder meine Firma noch mal Haus na toll was
jetzt jetzt kommt Schritt 3 der Heldenreise
überirdische Hilfe sie bekommen eine super Wasser
super eine Waffe Action endlich ja kommen Sie ja
eine super Waffe ist die geladen ja die scharf
sanktions durchsetzungsgesetz der Wagener
zu meiner Zeit haben Helden sowas gesagt wie
schweineback und nicht sonst musst du nicht sehen
ich meine also das sanktionsdurchsetzungsgesetz
das sorgt doch jetzt für schauen Sie unternehmen
ja die müssen jetzt zumindest begründen wenn
sie keinen Eigentümer ins Transparenzregister
eingetragen haben also gut äh wem gehört dieses
Scheißhaus von Wagner GmbH los es ist mir nicht
sagen begrüßen Sie es wenigstens zwingen sie mich
nicht das Aktions durchsetzungsgesetz anzuwenden
ich war und zwar mit allen Konsequenzen welche
auch immer das sein mögen ich habe vergessen
es gibt keine was ich geb auf ach komm sie
nicht so schnell ich gebe mir noch eine Chance
ist ich zeige Ihnen sogar
meine drei mit Eigentümerin
Moment Moment
ja sag mal den Namen stehen doch da gar nicht
drin die müssen doch aber doch die müssen doch
da drin stehen oder wenigstens in dem anderen
auch auf Italienisch hallo sie sagen sie mir
endlich wem diese GmbH gehört na gut dann schaue
ich eben selber nach so wollen wir mal sehen
Wellnessbereich im Westflügel Amt wo steckt der
Kerl wahrscheinlich auf dem Cayman Islands ach
so weit muss man gar nicht man kann sich
auch wunderbar in Deutschland verstecken
sehen Sie als Eigentümer im Transparenz
gestern müssen ja nur auftauchen wenn
sie über 25% der Kapitalanteil erhalten
Moment Moment das heißt wenn eine GmbH 4
Leuten gehört dann gehört sie keinen dann
ist ihre Superwaffe sowas wie Ladykracher
immerhin dafür dass die Immobiliendaten
verknüpft werden mit dem Transparenzregister
ach sie meinen die die Immobiliendaten
die keiner lesen kann mit dem Transparenz
Register in dem nichts drin steht
ja wahnsinnig so schwarz als ersten
April gibt's noch mehr gegen Geldwäsche
bargeldverbot bei Immobilien Transaktion
man konnte bis dahin Häuser bar bezahlen aber
sicher ich habe die 180.000 für mein Haus damals
bezahlt aber hat er nichts mit Kriminalität
zu tun das waren rein steuerliche Gründe
dann war das ja alles ganz umsonst
vielleicht wissen unsere Zuschauer
auch selbst wo sie abonnieren können
das jetzt noch zwei weitere Videos gucken
können stimmt unsere Zuschauer sind ja sehr klug